welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor kalyana Krishna Shiva
Ramakrishna a professor in both the
anthropology and forestry and
environmental studies departments at
Yale as well as chair of the South Asian
Studies Council professor Shiva
Ramakrishna's research interests span
environmental history political
anthropology cultural geography
development and science studies he has
published widely in all of these fields
with a regional focus on South Asia
today we will be talking about his new
work on environmental conflicts in India
welcome professor Shiva Ramakrishna
thank you for having me here how did you
become interested in forests and
agricultural issues in India that goes
back a while because this is not my
first career I started out right out of
college going to work for the government
of India and in that job I worked first
extensively in eastern India as a rural
development officer getting a lot of
experience doing rural development
projects mainly due with agricultural
development issues and later I worked
for some years in the Government of
India the Ministry of Environment and
Forests planning an exciting new program
on the development of waste lands and
forest conservation programs that the
India was getting very interested in
doing the ministry was new at the time
and they were really expanding their
activities in natural resources
management and forest conservation so
that experience gave me a lot of
exposure to these topics and developed
my interest in these topics and I
realized what I really wanted to be
doing was studying them and teaching
about them so I ended up going to
graduate school and wrote my
dissertation on forest management and
conservation
in eastern India and the project started
out being primarily interested in
efforts to involve local villagers and
people who live in around for us in the
care of the forest that they depended on
but we also were valuable natural and
national resource and these projects had
been funded by various organizations
like the World Bank and the Ford
Foundation and the government also but
studying these fairly novel attempts to
get cooperation going between the
conservation agencies and local people I
realized I really should be looking at a
much longer history of forest management
in the region which took me into my
research into the environmental history
of the area and the life and cultures of
various tribal and other agricultural
communities in the area and the
historical research took me back almost
400 years into the beginnings of the
colonial period and I ended up working
on that topic for almost 10 years for my
dissertation and Beyond and wrote
several books and articles on that topic
and that that was sort of how I got into
this ok so let's talk about your newest
project tell us a little bit about it my
since then my research moved into
related areas I got interested in more
broadly in human animal relations
wildlife conservation and the
relationship between environmental
change and agriculture especially in
certain dry areas where there was
chronic food and livelihood insecurity
and how that might be related to the
scarcity of water and the poor
conditions in which people farmed and
studying that took me also to new
regions I went after having worked for
more than a decade in eastern India in
Bengal and in Assam I now moved my field
research to south India to the state of
Thurman art which is on the southernmost
part in there of India in just across
the sea from
lanka and working there I began to study
initially dryland farming but got
interested in issues of migration and
related issues of wide-ranging conflicts
around Natural Resources and scarcity of
Natural Resources let's talk a little
bit about specifically about those
conflicts what are you finding
well I found that in any particular area
the conflicts related to a number of
resources simultaneously because in
these areas people dependent both on
farming and and forests and on livestock
and animal herding and so on the
conflicts simultaneously hinged on
terrestrial resources as well as various
agricultural commodities and of course
labor this despite the fact that these
are fairly well populated regions
there's always endemic sort of seasonal
scarcity of Labor which leads to a lot
of migration and then conflicts go
beyond the local area into neighboring
areas as well the escalation of
agricultural crises both there and other
parts of the country led to increasing
levels and intensity of conflict and one
of the things that I noticed was that
more and more cases were being filed
there is there was more and more
litigation taking place around these
conflicts and there was from about the
mid-1980s a spate of cases leading to
going all the way up to the Supreme
Court leading to a number of rulings
that the Supreme Court handed down and I
realized that there was a whole new
domain that was emerging as a result of
environmental conflicts in which the
courts were getting very heavily
involved and basically creating new
conditions for the management and new
understandings of what our citizenship
rights what our environmental qualities
what kind of quality of life especially
clean air and clean water and adequate
access to green amenities people might
have
as citizens so I began to get much more
interested in the role of the courts in
these environmental conflicts okay and
why is it important to look at these
environmental kinds of issues well I
believe these design extremely important
issues I mean today the world is facing
a number of very challenging
environmental problems cause we know
best the ones relating to global climate
change because they've been made so
prominent thanks to the tireless efforts
of the IPCC and former Vice President Al
Gore and their efforts even won them a
Nobel Prize so everyone knows about
climate change but besides climate
change there are serious problems
relating to the productivity of
Agriculture and most of the world the
majority of farming still takes place in
dry conditions reliant on seasonal
availability of moisture through
monsoons and other weather events and
such agricultural systems are in grave
crisis which is why we are having what
appears to be a growing growing problem
of food crises for instance in the news
there have been a lot of talk recently
of an impending food crisis in various
parts of the world some of it has been
attributed to some countries like the
u.s. growing biofuels but nevertheless
what you begin to realize is there are
conflicts relating to climate relation
to agriculture and of course the the
disappearance of wide variety of plants
and animals and that the loss of
biodiversity and and related issues of
water and air pollution and toxicity in
soils and so on so there are a lot of
problems and many of them are manifest
on a large scale in a large country like
India where all its star always
terrestrial resources and quite a bit of
its atmospheric resources have been
heavily used and managed for several
hundred years at this point the other
reason why I think India is a
particularly useful
example through which to study some of
these issues is its rapid economic
growth in the last 10-15 years India has
been growing at a remarkably fast pace
and like China this poses along with
China this poses major environmental
questions that have to be addressed
urgently and I think studying them in a
place like India is particularly
exciting and rewarding because it is an
open society it's a democracy no
conflict can be easily resolved because
so many groups are involved so many
constituencies have to be dealt with and
all this has to be done in a way that is
as far as possible participatory and
democratic so in terms of your newest
project what are you hoping to find or
learn through your research i'm as i
said i'm interested particularly in the
emergence of this expanded judicial
intervention in this attempts to manage
and resolve environmental conflicts in
india so what i'm hoping to find is the
new patterns and systems of
environmental management of government
that are emerging through a combination
of the efforts of the courts the
executive branch of government the
democratic aspects that are the
legislative branches of government and
the vigorous involvement and activity of
civil society organizations ngos
activists of various kind and the
relationship all this has to the
aspirations and struggles of small-scale
local communities and growing and
extremely prosperous large middle
classes in the big cities and how these
might be matched how this might be
reconciled and how they might be managed
in a way that conflicts are mitigated
and in but their environment is also
protected and nurtured okay so what is
your next step with this project well
the next step is as soon as I can get
some leaves to go off and do some more
fieldwork and looking forward to doing
that in a short while in a year or two
okay wonderful well thank you so much
for coming and sharing some of your work
with us today for more information about
professor shiva ramakrishna and his work
please visit our website at yale.edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale thank you very much
thank you